this is really important conservatives
for a long time we've just been so nice
and I still think we should be just and
do the right thing and virtuous but we
got to be a little less nice okay I
think we need to start wielding power a
little bit more I think we've got to
engage in law fair people always think
that the threshold for defamation suits
is too high because of the ridiculous
standards that by New York Times versus
Sullivan one that decision should have
been overturned it's ridiculous it
should be much easier to sue people for
intentionally lying about you but but
two
you can see now when conservatives push
back at all and when we've got a little
power and money behind us people cave
Rolling Stone caved Daily Beast caved
when they defamed me after the CPAC
speech and we're going to sick the same
kind of lawyers on the people that went
after Men what happened with that when
they defamed you so they came out they
said that I called it CPAC to eradicate
transgender people they rewrote what I
said they put words into my mouth and
then dailybeast called me genocidal so I
tweeted out I said you know this is
defamation